yeah I don't know I mean we haven't
really talked about it yet you've been
dating Rachel for how long a year ten
months you have been dating this girl
for a year and you still haven't had the
love talk well Todd look she's great
okay I I'm just not a big like love guy
[ __ ] a loved one yeah I love talk does
it love what is that hey oh why are we
giving Derek a hard time that's one cuz
he's dead
look I want okay let's ask you how long
Q do you go in relationship before you
tell your partner you love him
derek has been dating this girl for over
a year hundred ten months and he still
hasn't told her that he loves her
have you ever told a girl that you love
her before yeah
well that wasn't Rachel but at least we
know he's not dead inside he has a heart
he's a little cold right now but he has
I just don't understand how you could be
with a person for a year and a half and
not love them I never I never said it
louder we just I just haven't said it
yet and she said it to you kind of what
do you mean kind of what does that mean
hey um I kind of love you oh boy she
said at first that's not good that's
good what does mommy say at first the
guy is supposed to say at first okay
what if there's no guy in the
relationship oh yeah my bad we forget or
just everyone also didn't you say it's a
Brian Chris like the knives are gonna
get any less clean face down in the
dishwasher that's just not the way you
load a dishwasher Puri fat who made that
rule though not even about it's not even
about the rules it's just it's the way
like it's owed you to listen to me like
I love you and you're just not listening
you don't hear me er [ __ ] you love me
mmm technically I said it first but it
was an accident so it wasn't like I
planned it is the heat of moment and he
said it back right after telling I think
you should tell her how you feel she
deserves to know hey guys I just want to
let you know that it's Zak's birthday
and I baked him some cookies oh I love
you Kevin love you I love you girl love
cookies I just don't think Rachel and I
are there yet something
there you or something I think your beer
oh I'm drinking in your son mouth plate
hoodie you gently too much general
consensus with me you know you can talk
[ __ ] about me don't talk [ __ ] about my
hoodie no one did literally did you I
didn't know I was thinking about me